You break me Lisa!
When you think about it
"so bad its good" you probably think of a movie
with terribly horrible plays and bad manuscript.
A movie that is so bad that it becomes really fun to watch.
You see it and make fun of it with your friends because such a bad movie
takes himself so seriously.
"so bad it's good" film, goes all the way back to the 40's and 50's B movies.
The concept has always been the same:
They are "guilty pleasure" movies where you enjoy the movie because of its
Excessive use of clichés, overplayed plays
and awful room work. And that makes sense.
It's not hard to see the grumpy similarity in "Robot Monster"
in 1953, and "Sharknado".
But the problem is:
The analysis of "so bad it's good" usually stops there.
But I think you can go much deeper than that. I want to talk about what is at the core of it
This phenomenon and establish that the techniques
in "so bad it's good" is present in thousands of critically acclaimed
movie, and almost all the time
it is done on purpose. So let me explain:
"Michael"
"join me"
"so bad it's good" movie is an extreme version of
the idea that the audience enjoys theatrical and
exaggerated film that still takes itself seriously.
This concept is called "Camp". And it's another tool available
which is used by an instructor.
When you think of "Campy" movies, you probably think that they are always made unconsciously.
Like Tommy Wiseau, trying to film a serious movie,
which ultimately becomes the ultimate Camp classic.
But that is not the case. Instructors are constantly pretending
They take their film seriously to create a hero
new level of entertainment.
"But if everyone is sincere and serious, and pretends
it is an ordinary earthquake, or an alien invasion, or whatever it is,
then it transforms sincerity,
and then you can go even further with his villain,
which is "Sharknado". One can do insane things, "
"And that makes the movie even more fun."
"Camp" is not necessarily a genre
of film. Some movies may have elements of "Camp", without exclusively considering themselves as "so bad its good".
Perhaps the perfect balance of "Camp" and sincerity
"The Princess Bride". The film is actually wise written and performed,
while at the same time having a lot of "campy" and flat moments.
"You seem like a nice guy,
I would hate to kill you. "
"You seem like a nice guy. I would hate to die."
The sword fight blurs the border
between cartoon-like and serious. The risks are high and the stage
is professionally choreographed, but they also make random salters.
"Camp" makes "The Princess Bride" fun to watch, without making it a movie people make fun of.
It is extravagant, but never too much
and it always takes itself seriously.
In fact, "Camp" can sometimes save a movie.
Johnny Depp's performance turns "Pirates of the Caribbean" from a derivative
action movie, for a charming and fun franchise.
And that's because of his "campy", exaggerated, down-to-earth performance.
"You're certainly the worst pirate I've ever heard of"
"But you've heard about me."
Wes Anderson is a champion of "Camp".
His scenes are famously symmetrical so it borders on impossibility.
The camera constantly pans from one character to another,
He loves to use old-fashioned cartoon-like special effects,
And he ends up awkward conversations at the end of each sentence.
"Why do you see me as your enemy?"
"because your boyfriend stuck me in the back with left hand bag"
"she is my wife now"
"Congratulations"
Anderson creates charming and critical acclaim
movie, despite breaking numerous movie conventions.
"Campy" movie techniques give the film the extra flame that makes them
fun and shatteringly reciprocating.
"campy" instructors, roam the border between the impossible and the realistic,
So movies have some elements of "camp" while
at the same time possess a hint of seriousness.
So it doesn't seem like they are trying too hard.
"For me, Ralph plays a real person and makes him a real person,"
"and even the context"
"is this kind of invented country, in this just as invented
"version of the story, etc., so have"
"I'm a bit like trying to make it as realistic as possible, given"
"given what it is."
Excessive and "campy" filming is happening all the time. So this:
turns into this:
And this:
Quentin Tarantione loves "Camp".
If you have a villain, then make her a schoolgirl, and give her a gun as a weapon.
His love for the theatrical and exaggerated shows
basically that in all his films, lets characters
as if they are someone they are not.
"Come, let's get in character."
The result is extravagant,
but serious moments of bad or flashy play.
"Arrivederci"
"Camp" is also incredibly common in dialogue.
So many movies have characters to say things, no one really says.
"this is a line that cannot be erased, my friend"
But that doesn't make the dialogue bad. Or, ever do it.
"I didn't beat her. It's not true, it's bullshit"
"I didn't beat her, I didn't."
"oh, hi Mark"
But it's also a way to make movies fun.
Aaron Sorkin is one of the best screenwriters in the film industry, and
he loves "campy" dialogue.
In many scenes, he prefers excessive dialogue, rather than what one would actually say:
"Anne!"
"yes sir"
"touch my face, please"
Aaron Sorkin's famous "walk'n talk" style, from "Westwing"
feels extremely theatrical and constructed
It has been recycled to the point where it has been parodyed in almost all TV sitcoms.
He even parodies it himself:
"join me"
"I'm Aaron Sorkin"
His smart dialogue
is also recycled for an amazing degree:
"This is you and me talking Dana, I'm not other people"
"I'm not other people"
"Don't talk to me like I'm other people"
But it is not badly written.
It actually takes a very talented author to create a style that is
so easy to parody, but remains
exciting to see.
Technically, he is not original, but he still keeps it fresh.
We can feel his classic style, but we are not disgusted,
We appreciate it, for a mental illness actually, it gets closest
worshiped to the point where they make actors reproduce Sorkin's
style of talk shows.
"Camp" lets B movies, be movie,
and this is a concept we feel all over:
Mainly when a movie does something extravagant that would never happen in reality,
But the film still holds it in its sincerity.
"marriage"
And "The Room" fits in well with the concepts
about excessive and entertaining film production.
What makes the movie special is that it is one of the only "campy" movies that took itself completely
seriously, without any idea
just how excessive it was.
It is still "Camp", but it is unique because it is so innocently unaware of it.
"hey dog"
"you are my favorite customer"
"many thanks! goodbye"
And that leads me to the most important part of "Camp":
"Camp defies the binary thinking in film,
because it is both bad and good.
It breaks objectively many of the rules of film production.
unrealistic plays, flat dialogue, and extreme movie techniques,
is almost always frowned upon. But the crazy thing is, "Camp" is not bad.
Sometimes it is actually extremely entertaining.
Perhaps the most entertaining kind of movie that exists.
Too many instructors can be serious, and many instructors can be fun,
But not many can be so serious that they are funny.
I appreciate the "Camp" for movies shouldn't always be serious if they don't want to.
on the contrary, "camp" lets movies be
what they should be. entertainment.
So the next time you watch a movie, don't just take it into consideration
whether it is good or bad, think about whether you like it for its "guilty pleasure"
Consider whether it's so bad, but it's not a bad thing.
It's actually a good thing. It's good that it's bad.
"Do you want me to order a pizza?"
"whatever, I don't care"
"I've already ordered it"
"you think about everything"
Thanks for watching